[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein event
heute gibt es ein leckeres menü und zwar
mache ich falscher hase an
kartoffelpüree und leckere soße oder
bitte nicht sagt nicht an oder oder
drunter wirklich tempolimit julia gaß
der ziele setzen und eine petersilien
mantel oder sowas der wallstraße falsche
hinaus nicht egal ist nicht vegan es
hätte ein falscher hase und zwar nicht
wann das gericht so ist und hackbraten
und manager beim hat es früher halt in
so cook von harten brettern gebacken
mittlerweile also man kann das auch ganz
frei vorm und so habe ich das auch
gemacht ich habe eine ganz normale
kastenform verwendet und ich denke das
ist ein ganz tolles ostermenü zum
beispiel oder auch einfach so mal ein
sonntags menü
wenn ihr lust auf was leckeres habt ja
so darf ich es früher
nein ich muss nämlich zuerst einmal
zeigen wie mischung zubereitet und hier
vorne stehen auch schon die zutaten für
den falschen hasen brauche ich ein kilo
hackfleisch das ist jetzt vom rind zwei
esslöffel butter 2 zwiebeln 2
knoblauchzehen vier esslöffel gehackte
petersilie zwei scheiben brot ich nun
hier toastbrot ich habe ich zwei
teelöffel salz einen teelöffel
getrocknete rosmarin und pfeffer 22 us
cent und für die füllung nämlich drei
hartgekochte eier
ich habe ich noch kollisions und zwei
karotten ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal
die zwiebel und die knoblauchzehen und
die werden klein gewürfelt
ihr könnt auch gerne zugeben stifter
machen so macht morath ja ganz gerne im
alligator dann schneidet die zwiebel
nämlich nicht vorher aber wenn die
würfel haben wollt einfach verlieren
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die butter nehmen und im
topf schmelzen
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier die zwiebel und
knoblauch wirken rein und so bekommen
sie einfach durch das anbraten ein
bisschen mehr geschmack
während die zwiebel und knoblauch würfel
noch angebraten werden das dauert etwa
drei bis vier minuten kann ich hier in
der schüssel einfach schon mal die
restlichen zutaten verbinden
das heißt hier kommt das hackfleisch
schreiben darf ich jetzt rinde
hackfleisch genommen und habe einfach
hinter nacken genommen und den einfach
vorher prozent durch gewollt finde ich
etwas besser weil ich so selber
bestimmen kann wie fertig drin habe und
auch welches fleisch wirklich nehme da
jetzt die gehackte petersilie mit rein
die habe ich immer vorrätig im
tiefkühlfach von meinem kräuterhof bin
ich hab gesagt kräuter hochbeet die zwei
eier für die bindung da noch die gewürze
stadt rosmarin könnt ihr natürlich auch
gerne oregano zum beispiel nehmen dann
noch sein und das toastbrot dass er
kleiner ich jetzt so ein bisschen ihr
könnt auch semmelbrösel nehmen nicht nur
sie zwar nicht einreichen damit einfach
nicht zu viel flüssigkeit im markt
braten dann drin ist
[Musik]
jetzt sind die zwiebel und richtig schön
angebraten und duften lecker
die kommen jetzt hier mit rein
[Musik]
und den topf benutze ich jetzt gleich
weiter das frühere ich gleich wenn es
nicht mehr ganz so heiß ist und hier
mache ich jetzt schon mal den saucen
ansatz das heißt hier kommen jetzt 20
gramm butter haben nämlich den vollen
geschmack auf und zehn gramm mehl zum
binden
man muss eine kleine spitze
anbraten und jetzt gebe ich hier noch
100 gramm gewürfelte zwiebeln und 100
gramm gewürfelte karotten mit rein mache
ich eine richtig leckere soße kurz
anbraten und dann mit 500 milliliter
brühe aufkochen und afrikastudien
aufkochen
unternehmen die jetzt entweder
gemüsebrühe oder fleischbrühe jetzt
einmal kurz aufkochen damit einfach die
ganzen aromen vom topfboden wieder
gelöst werden und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich jetzt hier schon mal die hak
masse mit meinen händen planeten
[Musik]
ihr könnt es den hackbraten frei formen
und zum beispiel auf dem blech legen
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach die
kastenform sie hat löcher sowie der
außen auch schön knusprig und die fed
jetzt ein bisschen eltern im tirol oder
back translate kurz zur seite stellen
nicht vorm das jetzt ganz kurz hier
drinnen und legt dann gleich in die
kastenform reine also die hackfleisch
wasser verteilen
ungefähr schon mal die länge abmessen
und wer möchte kann hier ein bisschen
speck mit reingeben ich nehme dir den
türkischen rinder schenken
also passt immer bringt einfach bisschen
mehr geschmack mit rein
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt hier noch die füllung
rein und zwar könnt ihr da die
cornichons nehmen
die finde ich halt immer extrem lecker
die karotten könnt ihr gerne im ganzen
rhein legen oder vorher vierteln
[Musik]
damit die eier dazu und jetzt den braten
verschließen
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt das ganze im backofen und
weil ja ein bisschen fett auch unter
tropft mache ich das jetzt so der
hackbraten kommt hier oben rein
es war kost und da unten rein kommt noch
die glasform so dass alles was herunter
tropfenform landet und die später noch
nie zur sauce geben kann
während da hakt braten im ofen ist kann
hier die soße schon mal weiter köcheln
und zwar so lange bis die karotten gar
sind dann kann ich die soße einfach vom
herd herunternehmen bei uns gibt es als
beilage kartoffelpüree deswegen habe ich
jetzt hier schon mal kartoffeln geschält
und klein gewürfelt die mit wasser in
einem topf gegeben da kommt jetzt noch
salz dazu und die werden jetzt auch so
lange gekocht bis sie gar sind
und so lange kann ich in der küche
aufräumen und den tisch decken und dann
geht es gleich wieder weiter
jetzt ist der falsche habe fertig die
kartoffeln sind ihm gar die hab ich grad
abgegossen und jetzt kommt hier noch die
butter mit rein muss man natürlich
machen wenn die kartoffeln reis sind
dann kurz zerstampfen
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich hier noch die milz dazu
die könnt ihr vorher auch gerne noch
erhitzen und jetzt nur noch mit pfeffer
und muskatnuss abschmecken
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich hier die soße noch
abschmecken mit dem salz und pfeffer und
können sie dann einfach nur noch kurz
pürieren das mache ich jetzt hinten im
mixer und dann kann alles schon serviert
werden
[Musik]
fertig also angerichtet für mich echt
schön und ich habe es einfacher für ihn
noch mit etwas knoblauch salz gehört
man kann zum beispiel auch knoblauch in
der butter so ein bisschen anbraten
das auch sehr lecker oder röstzwiebeln
reingeben also kfw award läuft ich mal
so aus wie die mal so das kann ich ja
verantwortlich ist schön mit dabei
das ist doch schön hell und passte mal
hab ich drin wo ich einmal gestochen und
schon sehr stark und schlägt warten so
ein großes stück heimat schmeckt sehr
gut sagt doch was das sollte jetzt nicht
satt essen sondern unseren zuschauern
erzählen wie toll es schmeckt oder wie
sie wohl hungers betrieb also ihr wisst
schon ihr merkt schon murat weg des
gerichts verlegen und falls ihr das
rezept auch nach machen wollen dann geht
noch mal auf meinem blog cellestis
blog.de da steht noch mal alles ganz
genau für euch und ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr das menü zubereitet und fotos
davon hochladen und mich dann markiert
und schaue ich mal rein
sprich super er sich ohne visa und ihr
können die auch mal schreiben wir den
falschen hasen zubereitet denn von
region zu region ist es komplett
unterschiedlich die füllung es gibt eine
version mit wird mit drin also wieder
los
aber ich finde so fleisch im fleisch
immerhin außerdem passen ja aber ich
finde jetzt mal wie es mit der
türkischen leckere macht es ja das ist
echt berufen
da kommt also viel spaß nachmachen und
bist du mich zu machen gesehen
[Musik]